und uns erreicht so eben die meldung
dass im landkreis friesland eine impfung
stattgefunden hat ermittler der soko
maxim durchsuchen verschiedene
räumlichkeiten unter anderem im
impfzentrum roffhausen hier soll eine
mitarbeiterin kochsalz stadt impfstoff
gespritzt haben und unser kollege markus
hibbeler ist für uns vor ort ist uns
zugeschaltet und er hat einzelheiten
markus was kannst du uns zu dieser
razzia sagen ja bereits in den frühen
morgenstunden ging es hier los und zwar
im kompletten landkreis friesland einmal
wie hinter mir im impfzentrum roffhausen
aber auch in den drk stellen in
schortens und in varel fuhren zivilwagen
der polizei vor um diese zentren zu
durchsuchen denn wir haben es ja hier in
im landkreis friesland mit einem skandal
zu tun und man spricht mittlerweile von
bis zu 8000 kochsalzlösung verdünnt
worden sein sollen und die
durchsuchungen dauerten etwa vier
stunden an und ja vor wenigen minuten
hat der letzte zivilwagen der polizei
hier aus dem landkreis friesland den ort
hier verlassen beladen mit großen
kartons mit aktenordnern aber auch mit
computern wo sich die ermittler erhoffen
entsprechende informationen zu finden
markus die mitarbeiterinnen in dem
impfzentrum hatte bisher ja nur
zugegeben dass sie sechs solcher
kochsalz lösungen verspritzt haben soll
weil ihr ebene piontek impfung impfdosen
heruntergefallen sein wie kommt die
polizei die so kovacs ihn jetzt auf
diese unglaublich viel höhere anzahl von
bis zu 8000
da halten sich die ermittler bzw
erhältlich die polizei noch bedeckt es
soll hier nachher noch ein offizielles
statement gegen die normalen
ermittelnden beamten sagen hier dazu
noch gar nichts allerdings steht eben
diese hohe zahl im raum wenn es wirklich
diese hohe zahl sein sollte die mit
kochsalzlösung verimpft worden wäre dann
würde sich der skandal hat entsprechend
viel größer noch gestalten als
ursprünglich angenommen und dann ist
natürlich absolut von vorsatz die rede
deshalb auch angenommen wird dass eben
die
entsprechende dame die mitarbeiterin des
drk eben aus dem bereich der querdenker
bewegung kommt beziehungsweise da
durchaus militante absichten gehabt hat
aber wie gesagt das gilt es zu ermitteln
und die polizei wird nicht danach die
später auch noch dazu äußern man sieht
hier halt hinter mir eine riesenschlange
mehrere hundert menschen sind hier halt
heute hergekommen und sichtbar sie auch
noch mal impfen zu lassen sozusagen und
wenn sich dieser verdacht erhärten
sollte dass eben diese kochsalzlösung
hier verimpft worden sind dann müssen
halt entsprechend viele leute aus dem
landkreis friesland sich entsprechend
nachimpfen lassen was sind dann die
risiko und um akkus konntest du denn
schon mit den leuten sprechen wie
reagieren die auch so eine nachricht ich
glaube das ist ja nie schön wenn man
dann erfährt dass man eventuell davon
betroffen ist man hat gar keinen
impfschutz
genau wir haben ja bei bild auch
mehrfach jetzt darüber berichtet über
diesen im skandal und das ging es ich
komme ja auch selber aus dem landkreis
friesland aus varel und da hört man sich
halt auch ein bisschen um und die neue
leute sind natürlich geschockt davon und
viele haben sich eben aus sicherheit
jetzt schon ein drittes mal impfen
lassen weil sie ihm davon ausgegangen
sind dass sie nur kochsalzlösung bei uns
bekommen haben
ganz herzlichen dank für diese
information markus hübl ja für den
moment
[Musik]